what's up guys I'm Caleb McLaughlin and
this is actually me here we go
[Music]
Twitter
[Music]
Caleb McLaughlin hi I'm a big fan of
yours I'm looking forward to July 4th
but before that my friend's birthday
comes she also loves the series and then
I would like you to send me a video
congratulating her her name is Andrea I
hope he answered greetings from Spain
happy birthday
Andrea love you and hello spring next
excuse me but why is no one talking
about this strange but beautiful
photoshoot with Caleb McLaughlin it was
pretty strange to shoot big hands on a
roof with like bat wings and stuff I
don't know why but it is very strange
posted YouTube Caleb you did really good
in the new edition movie and on the B
team thank you I I appreciate that a lot
next Caleb and his sister named her
better duo I don't think you can I don't
think anyone can I can't Queen B
Wikipedia Caleb McLaughlin born October
13 2001 yes I was is an American actor
and voice actor he began his career on
the Broadway stage as young Simba in the
Lion King for two years yes I did one of
the longest-running symbols on Broadway
he plays Lucas and clear and the Netflix
series stranger things 2017
McLaughlin appeared in the b-team
miniseries the new addition story as
Rickey Bell that is a small part of my
career actually before the Lion King I
started off in an opera called lost in
the Stars I did that upstate New York
and Cooperstown at the glimmer glass
Opera House in between the time of Lion
King and Lucas I was on Law & Order Blue
Bloods another show called shades of
blue I was in another
show called forever there's a lot more
to my resume goink more twitter who
would you guys cast as live-action miles
for the MCU I'm struggling because I
don't want him to lose his expand acara
tidge I was gonna say Caitlyn mcLaughlin
I would love to play Miles Morales but
he doesn't have to lose his expanding
heritage I respect that 100% and also
don't forget he's actually he's black
too
it's an African American next Caleb
mcLaughlin be out there looking like
company if I could be joining Ben thank
you but no I don't look like Michael
Biehn I appreciate the compliment but no
I don't look like him next I really had
a biggest crush on Caleb McLaughlin and
sOooo now they're in one frame sooo I
was a really great guy I met him in
Korea that's a really interesting mix
though I would never think that anyone
would pair me up with soo but that's
pretty cool kaboom Instagram hey I got a
question for you Caleb whatever happened
to wills dog that is a very good
question well you'll have to see in when
season 3 comes out posted reddit all
right NCT 127 and Caleb McLaughlin yes I
did go see NCT one two seven it was a
great performance my first kpop concert
officially on the net I am dB
all right a native New Yorker
Caleb studied dance at the Harlem School
of the Arts HSA under barbering Lynch
a former Lion King producer and director
of dance at HSA is left-handed
that is so funny how they just ended
that but yes I did work with mr. Aubrey
he is a mentor of mine yes I am okay
that is very true I am left-handed it's
just weird how they put that in with a
more Twitter friend why are you so
obsessed with Caleb McLaughlin me
because he was there for me when you
I'm always there for you anytime
next how is Caleb McLaughlin so powerful
I don't know what to say I've never been
called powerful like that before
thank you ooh the wiki early life
McLaughlin grew up in Carmel a small
town and suburban New York the intended
ket primary school and later attended
George Fisher middle school for one year
he studied dance for a year at happy
feet dance school in Carmel New York and
then at the home School of the Arts
under our Burrage former Lion King
producer um yes I did grow up in Carmel
in a small town he studied dance later a
happy feet dance school that was during
the time I was in CHEM primary that
wasn't after George freshman middle
school and after my one year in middle
school I went into homeschooling for the
rest of my school life next Instagram
what Caleb McLaughlin and game a Durazo
have in common great dancers and
adorable dorks under appreciated but
don't forget we're both sexy you sing we
look sexy well I mean I'm just saying
right yo yeah even more Twitter I can't
breathe
why is Caleb McLaughlin in an Hambach
walking around with xox and I don't know
I went out to Korea and I got the chance
to get a tour at the palace over there
and dress up in some traditional Korean
garments it was a lot of fun
next what can't Caleb McLaughlin do no
joke there is a lot of things I can't do
trust me on that one I don't want to not
let anyone know my weaknesses well guys
I had fun reading your questions and
your comments
actually me signing out have a good day
[Music]